you're doing it again doing what again
my therapist says oh my god you haven't
moved in like three days you kind of
just walk around moaning everything yeah
it's that time of year the most
wonderful time of the year December
gloom you feel sad and anxious empty
hopeless helpless worthless guilty
irritable yeah you're a Sadie yeah sad
right no seasonal affective disorder oh
my god stop it with your therapy germs
okay my therapist says I don't sound
like that my damn reason I think my good
friend who has a ph.d says it's
perfectly normal to feel this way during
the holidays I go through it every year
you don't want to get out of bed seeing
everyone super happy with their families
more in fully opening the present you
got for your ex last year yeah it's
called December gloom but going to
therapy helped me see that there are
larger issues there xiety codependency
emotional hoarding but they just you
know get intensified during the holidays
because there's such a focus on
happiness may someone become one of
those people you know an emotionally
responsible person yeah they saw those
people who write off their flaws by
labeling it something clinical you know
like a Jimmy Jimmy he's working on it
but he has asked oh yeah he started
the other cats and soccer what are you
gonna do he has asked [ __ ] running
he's doing his best you know he cheats
on his wife and he beats her but what
are you gonna do he has [ __ ] he's
working on it Oh or like when people
will just like misdiagnosed themselves
for something more serious
you know like until then you see the new
girl comes out I'm like depressed no
you're not you're not [ __ ] no you love
adorable television you don't have a
crippling mental disorder but you know
there are people who do who once they go
to therapy it starts to get better how
see yeah well yeah especially when I
want the perfect text response okay so
that's what she said to me but what
should I say Mack maybe something like I
hear you okay all right I'll do it
good um we also clean this [ __ ] up
because I live here too and kind of
being an [ __ ] know what well I have
[ __ ] so Jesse I'll go to your
therapist to let you know I have Messi's
I have messy disease I am just messin
sorry
you